Given how wild and unpredictable the world
can be, wouldn’t life be so much easier
if we could see into the future?
Imagine being able to look ahead and know
what good or bad thing is about to come around
the corner.
If times have been hard for you, knowing you’ve
got something worth looking forward to might
give you just enough willpower to keep going.
Or if there’s a storm on the horizon, then
at least you would have enough time to prepare.
Unfortunately, being able to glimpse at future
events is a power that only a few – if any
– of us are blessed with.
Ask a cynic and they might tell you that seeing
the future is an ability reserved for scammers
and con artists at fairgrounds or selling
out magic shows in Las Vegas; all people just
trying to make a quick buck by telling their
paying customers what they want to hear.
You can’t part the cloudy veil that hangs
over the future for free, after all.
And then there are fortune cookies, those
crispy, sugary treats you crack open after
a meal, usually containing a piece of paper
with some pre-written, generic aphorism or
a vague prophecy.
If a human being can’t look into the future,
then surely those ambiguous predictions printed
on tiny slips of paper and left inside of
fortune cookies could never be accurate…
right?
Sage was one of the cynics.
Sure, some might argue he had every right
to be, having fallen on some pretty hard times.
Things weren’t exactly running smoothly,
and his life certainly had not taken the direction
that he hoped it would.
The trouble had started when, quite unexpectedly,
his landlord had raised the rent on his apartment.
Sage had been struggling to make ends meet
at work already, and the increase in those
monthly payments meant his hands were tied.
Eventually, he had no choice but to move out,
forced by the increase in rent to leave the
apartment he had once called home.
The one saving grace was that his friends,
Ash and Joey, had offered him a place to stay,
as long as Sage could throw them a little
bit of money to cover their own rent.
It was way less than his old landlord was
asking for, however even that came with an
unfortunate downside; the caveat that Sage
would have to sleep on their couch instead
of having his own room.
Sure, not the worst thing in the world, but
it does beat the floor.
But for Sage, it was far from an ideal living
situation.
To try and lessen the blow of having to leave
the independence and privacy of his own place,
Joey and Ash had decided amongst themselves
to throw a little celebratory dinner.
But of course, the key oversight to their
plan was that neither of them were all that
great at cooking, mostly surviving either
on ordering in delivery from local fast food
places, or anything that only needed a quick
nuking in the microwave in order to be made
edible.
All the same, Ash was adamant that their lack
of culinary know-how wasn’t going to stand
in their way.
He and his fellow roommate were going to lay
on a slap-up feast for their down on his luck
friend, Sage, the only way they knew how:
by ordering takeout.
“It’s… food,” he remarked, a little
lost for words after having seen his two new
roommates excitedly yelling ‘surprise’
at him the moment he walked through the door.
“Not just any food,” Joey replied, grinning
like a maniac.
“It’s ‘welcome to the apartment’ food!”
“You wanted to celebrate me sleeping on
your couch,” Sage said, staring at the mountains
of white paper oyster pails on the table with
red Mandarin lettering and ancient temples
painted on the sides.
“By ordering Chinese food?” he added with
confusion.
“Look, you’ve been going through it man,”
Ash cut in, explaining things that Sage already
knew.
“So, we figured this might lift your spirits.
Check it out, we’ve got it all here man,
dumplings, noodles, the works!
And for after…”
He produced a small box, the brand name ‘La
Choy’ emblazoned on its surface.
Inside were twelve fortune cookies, all individually
wrapped for freshness as the writing on the
box boasted.
“Hey, maybe you’ll get some good news
from one of these!”
Joey smiled, pointing at the box.
“I… thanks guys,” Sage eventually said,
chuckling quietly to himself.
He had to admit, what his friends were trying
to do for him, albeit a little excessive,
came from a place of good intentions.
Little did any of them know it was about to
change the very course of their lives… their
fortunes, forever.
Nearly two hours and several pounds of greasy
Chinese takeout later, the trio of roommates
were starting to wonder whether or not this
feast had been a good idea.
What had started as an innocent meal now had
them all feeling a little queasy, having eaten
so much that they were questioning their life
choices, and still with a few oyster pails
half full of leftover food.
Throwing out the empty paper containers and
leaving the rest in the fridge, Sage sat back
on the sofa, groaning in tandem with his friends
and cursing himself for having a third helping
of the chilli beef.
“Oh, damn, I almost forgot,” Joey said
weakly, reaching for the box of fortune cookies.
Opening it, he offered it to Sage, who immediately
put his hands up to refuse.
“No way, if I eat another thing, I sweat
I might have a heart attack,” he said.
“We don’t actually have to eat them,”
Ash interjected, picking up one of the plastic-wrapped
cookies at random.
“You only open them for the fortunes anyway.”
“Right, and I guess one of these cookies
is going to tell me that ‘Everything happens
for a reason’ or to ‘Keep my head up’,
or some other vague, non-specific prediction,”
Sage replied, making no attempt to mask his
sarcasm.
“Come on, man,” Joey urged, taking a cookie
himself before thrusting the box into Sage’s
hands.
“Sure, they’re never perfectly accurate,
but it’s just a bit of fun.
Besides, it’s all down to how you interpret
your fortune, you aren’t meant to take it
literally.”
With a cynical sigh, Sage gave in and grabbed
one of the remaining fortune cookies.
Tearing open the plastic packaging surrounding
it in time with Ash and Joey doing the same,
he then snapped the yellow, sugary shell in
two.
A tiny piece of paper was concealed within,
with an inscription printed on one side in
blue ink.
But before he had a chance to read it, Joey,
who was sitting next to him and had just done
the same, recited his own fortune out loud:
“Buy a ticket, trust your instinct and the
numbers will come,” he read.
“No way that’s what it says,” Ash argued.
“I’m not kidding,” Joey protested.
“Let me guess, the other side reads ‘This
fortune was sponsored by the State Lottery’?”
Sage joked.
Indignantly, Joey held his fortune up to his
friends' faces, letting them read for themselves
what he had already repeated aloud.
Being far from a betting man, Joey had hardly
ever made as little as a friendly, low-stakes
wager, let alone taken the chance on playing
either the State Lottery or a national one
like the Powerball.
The odds of winning just seemed like they
were stacked too high.
And yet, something about just how specific
this fortune was made Joey feel compelled
to maybe give it a try, considering taking
a chance and playing against those odds by
buying himself a ticket.
“My turn,” Ash announced, excitedly unfolding
her own paper fortune and clearing her throat.
“Keep your light on, the person you’re
looking for will be here soon.”
Even someone as cynical as Sage had to admit
there was something very strange about how
detailed these fortunes had been – or seemed
to be, at least.
Part of him thought maybe that was part of
their gimmick, making the text on the paper
that little bit less vague and generic than
those found in other cookies so that people
would find it easier to believe they were
an accurate prediction of the future.
But then again, it did seem like a strange
coincidence.
Sage knew that Ash had been trying to get
back into the dating scene, but was having
little luck on the more popular apps for meeting
new people.
Still, it’s not like the prediction on that
little piece would actually come true, nor
would Joey’s.
But if nothing else, the least it could do
was inspire a little hope in the pair of them.
Sage looked down at his own fortune, part
of him secretly wanting there to be another
optimistic message written on the paper.
After all, he needed a little boost in that
department, even if it was just for tonight.
Printed in blue ink were just three short
words:
“Look both ways,” Sage read, immediately
feeling his heart drop in disappointment.
“That one sounds way vaguer,” Joey commented,
highlighting the obvious.
“Well, we can’t all pick the nice fortunes,”
Sage retorted, screwing the tiny slip of paper
up in his hand and stuffing it into his back
pocket.
“They’re all just randomly generated anyway.
There are probably a million fortunes out
there that are all worded exactly the same
as ours.
It’s not like any of these will come true
anyway.”
Falling asleep on the couch later that night,
Sage had no idea just how wrong he was about
to be proven.
Almost to the same degree, he had little clue
as to what his fortune had actually meant,
but would only realize when it was too late…
Over the course of the following few months,
a lot seemed to be happening in the lives
of Sage’s two friends; and by contrast,
very little was changing in his own life.
The first surprise came when Ash had met a
new flame, a girl by the name of Skye.
In Sage’s head, it was just a fling, not
something he expected to last – although
he would think twice about saying it out loud
so as to not upset his roommate.
But, to his surprise, Ash seemed to be utterly
smitten with her newfound relationship, the
pair of them were happy, the very textbook
definition of head over heels for one another.
Both Sage and Joey were quick to voice their
support, but seeing what Ash’s fortune cookie
had predicted actually coming to pass got
the latter of them thinking.
Had that just been a lucky coincidence?
Was it just a case of right place, right time?
Joey wasn’t entirely convinced, despite
Sage telling him otherwise.
As far as he was concerned, it was all just
down to timing and confirmation bias.
Something that was impossible to predict or
foresee had happened that just so happened
to coincide with what they had read in their
fortune cookies.
But for his friend, it seemed an awful lot
like the fortune Ash had picked was one hundred
percent accurate, which meant he could be
too.
On top of that, Joey couldn’t help but wonder,
had the fortunes inside the cookies predicted
what was already going to happen, or did reading
those predictions make them become a reality?
Eager to find out if his own fortune cookie
had been telling the truth, Joey decided to
make a spontaneous venture on his way home
from work.
While riding the subway, he opened up the
website for the Powerball and went about purchasing
a ticket.
The minimum bet was only a few dollars, but
if his cookie prophecy was really a guaranteed,
accurate forecast of the future, then Joey
was in for good fortune in every literal sense
of the word.
His paper slip had told him to put faith in
his own instincts, and so, with trembling
hands, he input a series of numbers, going
with the first ones that popped into his head.
Getting back to the apartment that night,
Joey’s heart was racing, and he made sure
to let the others know about it.
Barely able to contain his excitement, the
pure unfiltered nervousness his friend was
exhibiting quickly became unbearable to Sage.
The draw for the Powerball was fast approaching
at the end of the week, although he was getting
sick of Joey claiming his numbers were sure
to be called, and pondering out loud what
he would spend the prize money on.
Sage’s cynicism still prevented him from
believing that his friend was going to win,
despite having witnessed Ash’s fortune come
true already.
It wasn’t until it happened right in front
of his eyes that Sage started to realize just
how wrong he might have been.
The night of the draw, the three roommates
– plus the new love of Ash’s life – were
gathered around the TV.
All of them, apart from Sage, were glued to
the screen, barely breathing.
The apartment was so quiet you could hear
a pin drop, the silence only broken by Sage
occasionally piping up.
“Watch, it’s not actually going to come
true,” he would assert, not intending to
put a downer on the proceedings, but merely
trying to encourage Joey to manage his expectations.
The other three shushed him; the numbers were
about to be called.
Gripping his ticket in one hand, the paper
slip containing his fortune in the other,
Joey felt his pulse rising, heart bumping
against his chest.
He wasn’t sure if it was out of excitement,
or nerves; in fact, it was more likely an
even blend of both.
On the screen, the multi-colored balls were
pulled one by one out of a spinning chamber,
each one marked with a different number.
Slowly, the first was revealed to the audience.
Joey, Ash, and her partner Skye could hardly
contain their excitement when they saw that
it was the same as the first number Joey had
picked out.
It was only when the second number was called,
and the others once again yelped in excitement
so loudly that Sage looked up from his phone
and took notice.
Before his very own eyes, he watched as each
number that the Powerball presenter unveiled
was met with a chorus of more and more excited
whooping from his friends.
They were all a perfect match for Joey’s
numbers, every single one.
He had won a huge sum of money exactly as
the fortune cookie had alluded to.
Even for someone as skeptical and disbelieving
of predicting the future, it was hard for
Sage to deny that both his roommates’ fortunes
had come true.
In fact, it was especially hard to be cynical
about it after watching firsthand as Joey
won the Powerball by ‘trusting his instincts,
which boiled down to him literally picking
the first numbers that randomly came into
his head.
But given how specific both Joey’s and Ash’s
personal prophecies had been, compared to
how vague his own was, Sage didn’t know
if what his slip of paper had said was a promise
of good things to come, or an ominous warning.
It also didn’t help that he just couldn’t
nail down what it meant.
‘Look both ways.’
For weeks and weeks on end, he mulled the
phrase over in his head.
It didn’t make sense for it to be completely
literal, leading Sage to try and think of
more metaphorical interpretations of his fortune.
He thought maybe there was something political
about it, that it might be urging him to consider
both of America’s two parties more equally
when casting a vote, rather than just blindly
ticking a box.
But the next election was still years away,
meanwhile, the predictions of Ash’s and
Joey’s fortune cookies had already come
to pass in the six months since they had first
opened them.
Frustrated and looking for the exact answer
behind his paper fortune, Sage was running
out of ways to reinterpret those three words
that apparently dictated his inevitable fate.
But the thing that pushed him into pure desperation
was the uncontrollable jealousy of witnessing
just how happy his friends were after their
fortunes became true.
He wanted to be happy for them and tried his
best to be.
But seeing Ash and Skye in their blissful
relationship, and Joey frivolously spending
his Powerball winnings on expensive clothing
soon became unbearable.
Having exhausted all other options, still
no closer to understanding what his fortune
was, Sage decided to visit the Chinese restaurant
they had ordered their food from all those
months ago.
But his heart sank as the staff working in
the restaurant told him that whatever was
written in the fortune cookies didn’t have
any bearing on the real world.
“You don’t understand,” Sage argued.
“My friends both had their fortunes come
true.
I mean the cookies we got from you predicted
it almost perfectly, down to the word.
I just need you to tell me what my one means!”
“I’m sorry, sir,” the young man behind
the counter replied.
“But it must just be a coincidence.
Fortune cookies can’t accurately tell the
future, it’s more about what you believe
the fortune means.”
Disheartened, Sage left the restaurant, his
head hanging low.
As he walked down the street towards the sidewalk,
he felt his phone vibrate in his pocket.
Taking a look at the screen, still walking,
he saw a text from Joey.
He was asking if Sage had any luck asking
the restaurant about his fortune cookie.
Maybe if Sage had done what that fateful slip
of paper had told him, as he stepped off the
sidewalk, then he would have seen the bus
speeding down the road towards him.
If you want to know the future, perhaps you
should only look at your own risk.
Sometimes knowing exactly what is destined
to happen to you can make it impossible to
avoid, a self-fulfilling prophecy, if you
will.
That is the warning given to any who dares
to take a prediction from SCP-377.
Now residing in a personnel break room at
one of the SCP Foundation’s sites, SCP-377
is the designation given to an anomalous box
of fortune cookies.
The fact that the box is seemingly capable
of replenishing itself at regular intervals,
refilling every twelve hours, happens to be
the far less interesting thing about it.
Any of the fortune cookies taken from SCP-377
are…
well, the cookies themselves are completely
ordinary by any and all metrics.
They taste exactly as fortune cookies should
and they aren’t made of any ingredients
apart from those you’d expect.
But somehow, without fail, every single fortune
found within one of these crispy, confectionary
clairvoyants manages to be one hundred percent
accurate.
They aren’t generalized predictions for
the future, definitely, none of them have
prophesized who the next winners of the World
Series are going to be, or who is next in
line to be President.
Every fortune contained in the SCP-377 cookies
are specifically tailored to the person who
opens them.
These fortunes have ranged from detailed foreknowledge
of upcoming events and changes in someone’s
personal life, to vague, unspecified allusions
to what lies ahead.
And, while always factually accurate and perfectly
aligned with the future, the predictions made
by these cookies are not always promises of
good fortune.
One researcher opened up an SCP-377 fortune
cookie only to read the phrase ‘It’s a
boy’ written on the paper.
Less than an hour later, his wife’s water
broke, and said researcher was soon welcoming
his new-born baby son into the world.
But another doctor was warned ‘You don’t
have long to live’, right before choking
on his own cookie.
Right there in the break room, that doctor
suffocated, killed by the same thing that
foretold of his death only moments before.
It is for that reason that SCP Foundation
personnel are given a warning before helping
themselves to a sugary shelled treat.
All staff are permitted to open a cookie from
SCP-377, after all, they are safe to eat.
And Foundation employees are also welcome
to read their fortunes, however, they only
do so at their own risk.
Now go and check out “SCP-261 PAN DIMENSIONAL
VENDING MACHINE” and “SCP-348 A GIFT FROM
DAD” if you’re still feeling peckish for
more appetizing anomalies and snack-worthy
SCPs to satiate your hunger.